A fleeting change in someone's face or body language can signal a lot of different emotions. Why do people's faces change when they're angry or sad? In this episode, we speak with a psychologist and expert in facial expressions, gestures, and other nonverbal behavior about how not speaking can speak volumes. I'm Audrey Hamilton, and this is Speaking of Psychology. David Matsumoto is a professor of psychology and director of the Culture and Emotion Research Laboratory at San Francisco State. University. An expert on facial expressions, nonverbal behavior and deception, he is director of Humintel, a company that conducts research and training for organizations such as the
面部或肢体语言的细微变化可以传达出许多不同的情绪。为什么人们在愤怒或悲伤时面部会发生变化？在本期节目中，我们采访了一位心理学家，他同时也是面部表情、手势和其他非语言行为方面的专家，探讨了“无声胜有声”的奥秘。我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿，这是《心理学谈话》。大卫·松本是旧金山州立大学的心理学教授，也是文化与情绪研究实验室的主任。作为面部表情、非语言行为和欺骗行为方面的专家，他还是Humintel公司的主任，该公司为以下机构提供研究和培训：
Transportation Security Administration, the FBI, and the U.S. Marshals Service. Welcome, Dr. Matamato. Thank you for having me. We are probably all familiar with the universal facial expressions of our emotions, you know, anger, joy, sadness, you know, those are some of them. Can you give examples of some of the less obvious facial expressions, I think you call them micro expressions, you know, where someone is maybe attempting to conceal his or her emotions, these are much harder to detect. Is that right? Micro expressions are unconscious, extremely quick, sometimes full-face expressions of an emotion, and sometimes they're partial and very subtle expressions of emotion. But because they're extremely
美国运输安全管理局、联邦调查局和美国法警局。欢迎您，松本博士。谢谢你的邀请。我们可能都熟悉情绪的通用面部表情，比如愤怒、快乐、悲伤，这些都是其中的一些。你能举一些不太明显的面部表情的例子吗？我想你称之为“微表情”，就是当一个人试图掩饰自己的情绪时，这些表情很难被察觉。是这样吗？微表情是无意识的、极快的，有时是全脸的情绪表达，有时是局部的、非常微妙的情绪表达。但因为它们极其
quick and because they're unconscious, when they occur, they occur oftentimes less than half a second, sometimes as fast as one-tenth of a second or even one-fifteenth of a second. Most people don't even see them. Some people do see them, but they don't know what they're seeing. They see something that has changed on the face, but they don't know exactly what it was that was changed. It's fleeting. It's very fleeting. But if you take a freeze frame on it on a video, you'll see that a lot of times there's a big facial expression that is very clear about what the person's mental state is. It all sounds very interesting, but how is this useful in the real world? You work with numerous organizations, like I mentioned, the FBI, the TSA, to help train interrogators and business people and the skill of reading people.
快速且无意识，它们出现的时间通常不到半秒，有时快至十分之一秒甚至十五分之一秒。大多数人甚至看不见它们。有些人能看到，但不知道自己看到了什么。他们看到脸上发生了变化，但不知道具体是什么变了。它是转瞬即逝的。非常短暂。但如果你在视频中截取定格画面，你会发现很多时候，面部表情非常清晰地反映了当事人的心理状态。这听起来很有趣，但在现实世界中有什么用呢？正如我提到的，你与联邦调查局、运输安全管理局等众多机构合作，帮助培训审讯人员和商务人士阅读他人的技能。
Tell us about your applied work in training programs. Well, learning to read microexpressions and nonverbal behaviors in general can be very valuable for anyone whose job it is. to understand other people's true feelings, their thoughts, their motivations, their personalities, or their intentions. So obviously there's an application for people who are doing interviews or interrogations. That would be people in the criminal justice system, law enforcement, and national security, intelligence, and those are the kinds of people that we primarily work with, because their job is to try to find about whether a person is concealing facts or concealing knowledge. or concealing something or has some information that would be useful for solving a crime
请给我们介绍一下你在培训项目中的应用工作。学习阅读微表情和一般的非语言行为，对于任何工作职责是了解他人真实感受、想法、动机、个性和意图的人来说，都非常有价值。显然，这对于从事访谈或审讯工作的人员有应用价值。这些人包括刑事司法系统、执法部门、国家安全和情报部门的人员，他们是我们主要合作的对象，因为他们的工作是试图查明一个人是否在隐瞒事实、隐瞒知识、隐瞒某些事情，或者是否掌握了有助于破案的信息，
or getting some other kinds of information. And so when one wants to be able to do that, it's very useful to be able to read these microexperions. But again, the application is very clear for anybody whose job it is to be able to get that kind of additional insight, what I call data superiority, for the individual who's observing others.
或者获取其他类型的信息。因此，当一个人想要做到这一点时，能够阅读这些微表情是非常有用的。但同样，对于任何工作职责是能够获得那种额外洞察力的人来说，这种应用是非常明确的，我称之为观察者相对于被观察者的“数据优势”。
So it could be for salespeople. It could be for the legal profession. It could be for health care professionals. Or, you know, psychotherapists, medical doctors, anybody, salesperson, I think I mentioned salesperson, anybody whose job it is to gain some additional insight about the person that you're talking with so that you can leverage that information
所以这可以适用于销售人员。也可以适用于法律行业。或者医疗保健专业人员。又或者是心理治疗师、医生，任何人，销售人员，我想我提到了销售人员，任何工作职责是获得关于谈话对象额外洞察力的人，这样你就可以利用这些信息
for a particular outcome. I imagine these skills are particularly important in intercultural exchanges. Are facial expressions and gestures different? in other cultures, and can you give us some examples? Well, facial expressions of emotion are universal in the sense that we all, everybody around the world, regardless of race, culture, nationality, sex, gender, et cetera, and whatever the demographic variable is, we all show the same facial muscle expressions on our faces when we
来实现特定的结果。我想这些技能在跨文化交流中尤为重要。面部表情和手势在不同文化中是否不同？你能给我们举些例子吗？嗯，情绪的面部表情是通用的，意思是无论种族、文化、国籍、性别等人口统计变量如何，全世界每个人在感受到相同情绪时，脸上都会表现出相同的面部肌肉表情。
have the same emotions. Now, of course, the question is context will moderate all of that, and what kinds of things bring about different emotions in different cultures. So there are, of course, there are cultural differences and large individual differences in when people express emotions and how they express them when they feel their emotions. But if there's no reason to change anything when people are feeling extremely strong emotions and they can express it freely, they will express those emotions on their faces in exactly the same ways. Gestures are very different. There are very many different types of gestures. And so the two types of gestures that, the two types of gestures that
当然，问题在于环境会调节这一切，以及在不同文化中，什么样的事物会引发不同的情绪。因此，人们何时表达情绪以及在感受到情绪时如何表达，确实存在文化差异和巨大的个体差异。但如果没有理由改变任何事情，当人们感受到极其强烈的情绪并能自由表达时，他们会以完全相同的方式在脸上表达这些情绪。手势则非常不同。手势的类型非常多。我们通常研究的两类手势是“言语说明符”和“象征手势”。
we generally work with are called speech illustrators and emblems. Speech illustrators are these gestures that accompany speech that when you see a person using their hands when they're talking to illustrate a point. They're like animation. They're like how we use our voice. They're you know they're they're functionally universal in the sense that everybody around the world uses hand gestures as speech illustrators but people around the world differ in the amount that they you do them and in the form. So if you can picture people waving around, some people in different, some cultures wave around their hands in a certain way. Some people point when they talk. Some people
言语说明符是伴随言语的手势，当你看到一个人在说话时用手来阐述观点。它们就像动画。就像我们使用声音的方式。它们在功能上是通用的，因为全世界的人在说话时都会使用手势作为说明符，但世界各地的人在使用的频率和形式上有所不同。所以如果你能想象人们挥动手臂，在不同的文化中，有些人以特定的方式挥动手臂。有些人说话时会指指点点。有些人
are doing various different types of things with their hands when they talk. So the form in which the illustrators occur are different, but the function is the same across different cultures. Emblems is another type of gesture. These are generally culturally specific. These are gestures that refer to specific words or phrases. So if you can imagine, the listeners can imagine the thumbs up, which has a meaning around the world, which is like okay or good. These things are culture specific. So every culture, just as every culture has a verbal vocabulary,
在说话时用手做各种不同的动作。所以说明符出现的形式在不同文化中是不同的，但功能是一样的。象征手势是另一种手势。这些通常是特定于文化的。这些手势指的是特定的词语或短语。如果听众能想象一下“竖大拇指”，它在世界各地都有含义，比如“好的”或“不错”。这些东西是特定于文化的。所以每种文化，就像每种文化都有口头词汇一样，
different verbal vocabulary, every culture creates a vocabulary of emblematic gestures that correspond to certain types of phrases that they think are important to have an adjustment. gesture. So those are very culture-specific. Now, what's really interesting about that is that some of our most recent research published a couple of years ago has shown that some gestures are beginning to be universally recognized around the world, like head nods for yes and head shakes for no. Of course, there's places around the world that still do them in different
不同的口头词汇，每种文化都会创造出一套象征性手势词汇，对应于他们认为重要的短语。所以这些是非常特定于文化的。现在，有趣的是，我们几年前发表的一些最新研究表明，一些手势开始在世界范围内被普遍认可，比如点头表示“是”，摇头表示“不”。当然，世界上仍有一些地方以不同的方式做这些动作，
ways, but they are increasingly being recognized universally around the world, probably because of a lot of shared mass media because of the internet or movies and things like that. So in summary, with nonverbal behaviors, there's some aspects of it that are very universal and some aspects of them that are culture-specific. Some of your research has involved the study of blind athletes. I thought this was interesting. Can you tell us how that research has furthered your understanding of human emotions? Yeah.
但它们正越来越多地在世界范围内被普遍认可，这可能是因为大量的共享大众媒体，因为互联网或电影之类的东西。总之，关于非语言行为，有些方面是非常通用的，有些方面是特定于文化的。你的一些研究涉及盲人运动员。我觉得这很有趣。你能告诉我们这项研究是如何加深你对人类情绪的理解的吗？是的。
Well, to tell you the truth, one of the pervasive questions about facial expressions of emotion in the past has been whether they're universal or not. I think there's very conclusive evidence about the universality of facial expressions of emotion. Then the next question becomes, where do they come from? Because it could be that we are all born with some kind of innate skill that is an evolutionarily based kind of adaptation that we share with non-human primates and other animals. Or it could be that humans have just all around the world learn it, regardless of where they are from the time that they're infants.
说实话，过去关于情绪面部表情的一个普遍问题是它们是否是通用的。我认为关于情绪面部表情的普遍性已经有了非常有力的证据。那么接下来的问题是，它们来自哪里？因为这可能是我们与生俱来的某种天生技能，是一种我们与非人类灵长类动物和其他动物共享的进化适应。或者，这可能是全世界的人类无论来自哪里，从婴儿时期起就学会了它。
So it could be something that is learned or something that is biologically innate. Now, studying blind individuals and especially congenitally blind individuals is a particularly great thing to do to address this particular research question because when you study blind individuals and you study their expressions, you know that as long as they were congenitally blind, that there is no way that they could possibly learn to see those expressions and put them on their faces from birth, they've been blind from birth. And so when you study a population like that, it helps you
所以这可能是后天习得的，也可能是生物学上与生俱来的。研究盲人，尤其是先天性盲人，是解决这个特定研究问题的特别好的方法，因为当你研究盲人并研究他们的表情时，你知道只要他们是先天性盲人，他们就不可能通过观察学习到这些表情并从出生起就表现在脸上，他们从出生起就失明了。因此，当你研究这样的人群时，它有助于你
address a certain research question. And so in the studies that we've done, we've actually studied the spontaneous facial expressions of blind individuals from around the world, from many different cultures. And we showed that in the same emotionally evocative situations that blind individuals produce on their faces exactly the same facial muscle configurations where the same emotions as cited individuals do. And again, because these are individuals, who are blind from birth, there's no way that they could have possibly learned to do that by seeing others do it. And so it leads me to think, and many others, to believe that the ability to have facial expressions of emotion is something that we are biologically in Aden that we're all
解决某个研究问题。在我们所做的研究中，我们实际上研究了来自世界各地、许多不同文化的盲人的自发面部表情。我们发现，在相同的情绪诱发情境下，盲人脸上产生的面部肌肉配置与视力正常的人在相同情绪下产生的完全一样。同样，因为这些人是先天失明，他们不可能通过观察他人来学会这样做。因此，这让我和许多其他人相信，拥有情绪面部表情的能力是我们生物学上与生俱来的，是我们所有人
born with. I've done judo for 48 years of my life here, and I've been fortunate enough to be part of the, part of our Olympic movement in judo. I was the Olympic coach. for the 1996 and 2000 Olympic Games for the United States. We studied the expressions of the athletes in the regular Olympic Games, so these are all cited individuals. And we studied their expressions right at the moment they won or lost the medal match. Okay.
出生时就具备的。我练柔道已经48年了，我有幸参与了我们的柔道奥运运动。我是1996年和2000年美国奥运代表队的柔道教练。我们研究了奥运会运动员的表情，这些人都是视力正常的。我们研究了他们在赢得或输掉奖牌赛那一刻的表情。好的。
And we're taking photographs, these are high-speed photographs, eight shots per second with a very expensive camera. And so we can track the expressions, you know, in minute second-by-second, or fractions of a second, resolution right at the time of winning or losing the match. And we also could see the expressions of the same athletes on the podium 30 minutes later in a social context. So we could do that comparison. Two weeks after the Olympic Games, what happens in every Olympics, what happens in every Olympics
我们拍摄了照片，这些是高速照片，用非常昂贵的相机每秒拍摄八张。因此，我们可以在赢得或输掉比赛的那一刻，以每秒或几分之一秒的分辨率追踪表情。我们还可以在30分钟后的社交场合中看到同一运动员在领奖台上的表情。所以我们可以进行那种比较。奥运会两周后，每届奥运会都会发生的事情，每届奥运会都会发生的事情
is the Paralympics rolls in into town using exactly the same venue. So my guy was there still. And every sport has a different disability for judo, for judo it's blindness. And so all the judo athletes in the judo Paralympic games are all blind. Half of them or some degree of them are congenitally blind and some are acquired blindness through some kind of disease or accident. There are no differences between them, by the way. But anyway, we were able to do the same kind of study with the Paralympic judo blind athletes in the Paralympic games.
就是残奥会会在同一个场地举行。所以我的团队还在那里。每项运动都有不同的残疾类别，对于柔道来说，是失明。所以残奥会柔道比赛中的所有柔道运动员都是盲人。他们中有一半或某种程度上是先天性失明，有些是通过某种疾病或事故获得的后天失明。顺便说一句，他们之间没有区别。但无论如何，我们能够在残奥会中对残奥会盲人柔道运动员进行同样的研究。
When you compare the expressions of the blind athletes in the Paralympic games to the sight of the athletes in the regular Olympic Games, What you find is that for the winners, they all do the same. Winners and losers, they all do the same thing. And we measure the exact facial muscle movements that are occurring right at the time of winning or losing that match. So I think the correspondence,
当你将残奥会盲人运动员的表情与常规奥运会视力正常运动员的表情进行比较时，你会发现对于获胜者来说，他们都做同样的事情。获胜者和失败者，他们都做同样的事情。我们测量了在赢得或输掉比赛那一刻发生的精确面部肌肉运动。所以我认为这种对应关系，
the correlation between the, in the correspondence between the facial muscle muscle movements was something like 0.9 or some incredibly high number that you never see in research nowadays, so that the correspondence is amazingly high between the blind and the sighted athletes. What's really interesting about sighted athletes, blind athletes is this. If we ask our listeners to show on their faces,
面部肌肉运动之间的相关性和对应关系大约是0.9，或者是一个在当今研究中从未见过的极高数字，因此盲人运动员和视力正常运动员之间的对应关系高得惊人。关于视力正常运动员和盲人运动员，真正有趣的是这一点。如果我们让听众在脸上展示，
what do you do, what do you think you do on your face when you express anger? Everybody can give you something. And it'll be pretty much accurate. And the reason is because all of us have seen it. We've seen it in ourselves if we've seen ourselves angry in a mirror or we see it in others when they're angry. So we see it, we know what it looks like,
你认为你在表达愤怒时脸上会做什么？每个人都能给你一些东西。而且会相当准确。原因是我们所有人都见过。我们在镜子里看到过自己愤怒的样子，或者在别人愤怒时看到过。所以我们看到了，我们知道它看起来是什么样子的，
we've seen ourselves do it, we know what it feels like. A blind athlete has never seen it. So if you ask a blind person, hey, show me what you look like when you're angry or when you're sad or something else. You'll get something that's close, but you don't get the exact facial muscle movements that occur when those emotions occur spontaneously. However, when it occurs spontaneously, the exact facial muscle movements are exactly the same. So blind individuals produce them spontaneously, but don't
我们见过自己做这个表情，我们知道它感觉是什么样的。盲人运动员从未见过。所以如果你问一个盲人，嘿，给我看看你生气或悲伤或其他什么样子。你会得到一些接近的东西，但你得不到当这些情绪自发出现时所产生的精确面部肌肉运动。然而，当它自发出现时，精确的面部肌肉运动是完全一样的。所以盲人个体自发地产生它们，但不会
produce exactly the same thing when you ask them to pose it, whereas sighted people do. Interesting. And so this is, to me, another example of how there's differences between the blind and the sighted and why they are, because this is a biologically innate thing. They can do it when it's spontaneous. Well, thank you, Dr. Matsumoto for joining us today. It's been very interesting. My pleasure.
在你要求他们摆拍时产生完全相同的东西，而视力正常的人会。有趣。所以对我来说，这是盲人和视力正常者之间存在差异的另一个例子，以及为什么会这样，因为这是一种生物学上与生俱来的东西。当它是自发的时候，他们能做到。好吧，谢谢松本博士今天加入我们。这非常有趣。我的荣幸。
For more information on Dr. Matsumoto's work and to hear more episodes, please go to our website at speakingofpsychology.org. With the American Psychological Association speaking of psychology, I'm Audrey Hamilton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
有关松本博士工作的更多信息以及收听更多剧集，请访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org。我是美国心理学会《心理学谈话》的奥黛丽·汉密尔顿。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。